oh hello welcome back to the GameSpot
stage here YouTube gaming and I'm
delighted to be joined by sky my friend
how are you doing nice to meet you man
this is you looking forward to this one
oh yeah
this is a nice little moment for you
wouldn't be YouTube's stage without
having one of the most prominent
youtubers on there you've obviously been
doing this for such a long time and
you've reached a wonderful benchmark
which Ryan is here to tell us about
absolutely sky you know you've you've
been on the platform for over five years
been really investing in YouTube it's
been a huge part of your entertainment
career I mean just see you start off
doing runescape videos and now be one of
the most popular minecraft channels in
the universe oh we couldn't be more
proud of you at YouTube man we we love
you thank you so much for all the hard
work you guys do yeah so in light of
that we wanted to present you your
Diamond Award officially on stage and
say congratulations and thank you so uh
it's heavy let me give that to you it's
really heavy I don't want to like I
don't want to get on like a motion
theory but my god I think I might well
we can use your tears to wipe off the
prints on there I know that'll be
alright
random applause congratulations you guys
pop it out for this thing is so heavy
it's like 10 pounds guys like that's
what this thing I could use it
well congratulations we love you over
there you get all much and thank you so
much let me surely solutely can't wear
where's the camera is that it right
right there boom I have to ask where are
you gonna put it that is uh that is a
good question probably at my office's
like right on my route of my little desk
in Josh just behind just behind your
seat yeah I'm the toilet you know I'm
going to like I'm gonna use this as a
paperweight I feel like it no showing
though you're gonna need big pieces of
paper really not exaggerating it's
really heavy we should probably wrap
this up there yeah yeah Ryan thanks so
much for that congratulation Scotty if
you can hold it with one hand
yeah thank you oh my it's work I will be
back in just a minute and we're gonna
get CaptainSparklez on I'm talking about
some minecraft so stay there